hello guys I'm Ryan right I am Jerry
don't normally covered games however
this trailer of moral Kombat X Kombat
pack 2 gameplay trailer I primarily did
it because I wanted to show it to Jerry
is it extra 10 your questions annoy me
sorry
cool Mortal Kombat spine ripping I'm
excited well Jerry there's some special
don't barf on me there's some special
characters in there oh and that's why I
want to show you this video I think
you're gonna like this I think I know
what you're gonna hear I've heard rumors
of who I don't want to say who knows all
right or nothing but I think you're
gonna be pleasantly surprised really
okay Peggy 18 Peggy's a good girl oh
[ __ ]
we're gonna get her to get cheese no it
was [ __ ] nice
don't try borings back
there's no plan
Wow another returning character
Ardex don't ya hahaha watch that use the
wave move whoa is that another one
Oh
ah
that looks sweet huh
I like moral code I play if you go to
that cyber channel you can find a video
me playing Mortal Kombat X fun ass game
is this like a deal like a pay for
downloadable content yeah yeah okay says
we're like Jason and Predator King yeah
exactly
but adding Leatherface and the xenomorph
to the mix yeah that's exciting we're
movie fans so it did not really the big
gamers but the movies this is a big deal
for people like us so if you have both
of those expansions those downloadable
content packages can you play as
predator and alien and fight yeah you do
AVP yeah or Jason versus leather yeah ah
that's why they showed Jason versus
leather face at one point that was oh
really I somehow I missed I was too
focused on loved it yeah
sure you right unless it was Jason oh
[ __ ] oh well it's awesome oh it's so
cool alright alright gotta play this
that I gotta put I mean it looks it
looks very intense like it looks like
you can't play for very long without
getting some kind of headache but it
does look [ __ ] cool now Jerry in a
brutal sort of way yes before I showed
you this video ah I told you earlier
that there's a video here that you're
gonna like yeah I don't want to tell you
what it's about
oh [ __ ] and you'll be pleasantly
surprised how do you feel I mean I was
very excited ii Leatherface showed up I
was like ah
mission complete that was not expecting
that yeah because Jerry is a huge horror
movie fan yeah that's like his main
forte and he loved her and he does love
horror and he loves Horrors he put the
two together love ever bought a serial
killer movie Jerry reasons to Jerry is
the name of the serial killer movie and
portrait of a killer
Gary Morton because little kids Henry's
brother Henry is like plucky brother
yeah I can't quite get it right looking
at this it's a very exciting thing to do
I think it's a great marketing move
because for people who don't [ __ ]
play Mortal Kombat well look at this and
go well looks like a lot of fun I've
never played a game with Leatherface
into before you know it's perfect
marketing and they can theoretically do
this forever they could just take up
characters we like get the licensing and
put them in the game and then someone's
gonna be like I gotta play that I have
to play his little face the way the
xenomorph moved though yeah kind of made
me laugh well that's just like sheer I
think is it's just your force of the
demo because that ain't like that
xenomorph is just like decimating his
opponent I know but you know it's just
like so fast in the way he or her movie
yeah every day all I don't know what the
what the mechanics are know if they're
male and female or just being number one
uh get away from her you [ __ ] but ya
know it's just like she's moving so fast
and just whipping that tail around like
she's [ __ ] her up to a comical degree
it's almost funny cuz there's so much
carnage and she is so like there is
she's just beating the [ __ ] out of her
opponent yeah yeah and I like how one of
the deaths does you know more baby
verse out however you can do that as one
of the fatalities oh you would have to I
know that's brilliant that's so
brilliant because it's not one of those
things where it's like let's include
this horror movie character and have
them move and be exactly like other
characters they just look different yeah
they're like tailoring the way these
characters move their combos
specifically to these characters like
the way all their movements are it's
it's not like playing some stupid app
game work you know what I mean oh yeah
as well they should do like they should
personalize each character and that
makes it more worthwhile when they you
know come out with one of these four
character bundles here and there yeah
it's like if they really take their time
that's where I'll get people to stick
around beyond just oh cool you know
mm-hmm so if you have unique combos
that's what's up who would you like to
see in this what I'd like to see in this
I have I have both terminators the t1000
loves and the TA
that's a good call 200 wheel guns liquid
Terminator would move like that
character and killer instinct ah
Terminator would be great um wills I
mean earlier yeah yeah loser another one
another earlier Mortal Kombat game I
can't remember maybe I don't remember
now I want to say yeah but I might just
yeah thank you might be my imagination
yeah um there's got to be another like
really great care you know I would like
to see but it's the characters not big
enough Sam from trick-or-treat I thought
about that too but the thing about Sam
is like Sam's really small and super
cool and Sam's like main mode of
existence is not violence or or dementia
like Sam is more spectral I don't know
exactly I describe like Santa's just go
around [ __ ] people up like there is a
way where you can like match respectin
Hellraiser
Hellraiser would be Hellraiser yeah
Santa bite from Hellraiser a pinhead if
you had yeah or any of them really
shatter or any of those guys like that
would be cuz those are all [ __ ] up in
BDSM and and and you know
Ghostface yeah it's the same reason why
I wouldn't necessarily care to see
Michael Myers in this it's like you know
yeah I'm can't have too many slow stocky
guys with one primary weapon Rocky
Balboa the dude Godzilla um no John
McClane come on John McCole we have to
be I feel like they have to be somewhat
larger than life Danny ocean Danny Trejo
danger machete machete machete would be
perfect
machete would be [ __ ] or Elmo yet not
machete would machete machete would fit
in this world
yeah machete would be the perfect choice
yeah machete would be you know also be
cool um Huma therma from Kill Bill yeah
be cool it's fun yeah hope you guys take
our suggestions Mortal Kombat team
listen guys
ooh why are you doing this other people
kiss their muscles I take my guns well
look no I don't want to do that I
subscribe to the real rejects become a
reject reasons to GRE playlist on this
channel featuring this guy's lickable
face ah what's this room bring out the
kid wait no he does that's it again yeah
it's from pulp fiction
yeah it's rejected right where that
actor makes love to Ving Rhames sweet
lovin dank ass stubs on this playlist is
a channel here hosted by Jerry Aaron you
know I mean missed reader a couple of
times asked for a shout out swords crust
this time I get one Oh Simon P today cuz
the epic collaboration notice me sempai
notice my sempai and bye
sempai you're like idiots you say wife
of P you once said that to me
listen guys okay this guy drew a [ __ ]
awesome picture take a look at that
picture
tyro magnus v ryan right dawn of
reactions instead of drawing or is it
filtered why am i Superman because he
gets a Wonder Woman is that why I'm
Superman I mean it's just like this
doesn't make sense and when people do
videos of us Tyrone's always bad man
when Tyrone's favorite superhero is
Superman and my favorite superhero is
Batman I think is this because of you
and Veronica it's like because you guys
are a pair than you have to be Superman
and Wonder Woman whoa dude are you
saying that mean mystery wants me to
break up with Veronica no I could draw
me correctly no not at all I'm saying
that's why he's Oh horrible accusation
that's not what I said at all I do like
I said that's a major conclusion it
jumped you yeah I said the opposite
thing thank you for this photo um it's
really sexy it's really sexy and he said
what's good Veronica I'll see
on behalf of Veronica listen I can't
make sex jokes about Veronica anymore
her mom got very upset with me said I
crossed the line too vulgar it's not
even funny it's disrespectful and while
we share our differences
Veronica cannot be made fun of about any
more sex things but damn - I got some
shows rages you need to keep a journal
and just write them down and you'll have
gotten them out and then just burn the
germs oh I got good cancer I know you
it's okay
write them down all right look sounds of
Veronica
dude just on our own time